on twitter president trump welcome the
country into the second year of what he
calls quote the greatest witch hunt in
american history
adding there's still no collusion with
Russia only collusion by Democrats on
Fox the president's lawyer went further
in this case I think we're gonna have to
look into whether we can challenge the
legitimacy of the entire investigation
maybe a special process prosecutor
special counsel never should have been
appointed not based on an illegal leak a
year into the special counsel probe new
details emerged about its origin in the
summer of 2016 and a major pivot by the
FBI we cannot find a case that would
support bringing criminal charges on
these facts three weeks after the
Clinton email announcement the FBI
launched a counterintelligence
investigation codenamed crossfire
hurricane probing Russian contacts with
the Trump campaign by early August 2016
according to text messages FBI agent
Peter struck later removed from the
Russia case for anti-trump bias went to
the US Embassy in London and interviewed
a key witness an investigative source
confirmed to Fox details first reported
by the New York Times that the FBI also
obtained phone records and other
documents using secret national security
subpoenas The Times said there was at
least one informant who met with Trump
campaign aides Carter Page and George
papadopolis the president claimed in
another tweet that the Obama FBI spied
on the Trump campaign and said if true
it's bigger than Watergate I haven't
spoken with him directly about that but
certainly seen the reports and if there
is any truth to that it should certainly
be looked into by August 2016 then CIA
director John Brennan briefed than FBI
director James Comey as well as the
Senate Minority Leader Harry Reid on
russia's election interference this
letter from Reid became one of the first
public acknowledgments of the secret
Russia probe in October the FBI and
Justice Department obtained the first
surveillance warrant for Trump campaign
aide Carter page based on opposition
research funded by the DNC and Clinton
campaign the so called Trump dossier
almost two years since the FBI opened
its Russia investigation the president's
legal problems extend to his personal
dealings with lawyer Michael Cohen with
a new report that missing files
motivated the lead
Oh Cohen's financial records to the
media